it's one of the great paradoxes of
mental life that we are often unable to
access our true feelings about important
matters what we really think about for
example the character of a friend or the
next best move we should make in our
career or our stance towards an incident
in childhood all of our conclusions on
such critical topics can remain locked
inside us part of us but inaccessible to
ordinary consciousness
what we operate with instead are surface
and misleading pictures of our
dispositions and goals we may settle in
haste or fear on the most obvious
answers our new friend is very kind we
should aim for the most highly paid job
our childhood was fun
we ignore our deep truths first and
foremost because we are trained to
solicit them no one ever quite tells us
that we might need to exhibit the
patience and wiliness of an angler while
waiting at the riverbank of our deep
Minds
we've been brought up to act fast to
assume that we know everything
immediately and to ignore that
Consciousness is made up of layers and
that it's the lower strata that may
contain the richest most faithful
material
we may also be hesitant because the
answers that emerge from any descent
into the depths and subsequent communion
with our inner pilot can sound at odds
with the settled expectations we have of
ourselves in daylight it might turn out
that we don't in fact love who we're
meant to love or that we're scared and
suspicious of someone who's pressing us
to trust them or that we're deeply moved
and sympathetic to a person we hardly
know
it is the profoundly challenging nature
of our deep conclusions that keeps us
away from our inner sanctum we
prioritize a sense of feeling normal
over the jolting realizations of the
true self
the steps that we need to take in order
to check in with ourselves are not
especially complicated we need to make
time as often as once a day to lie very
still on our own somewhere probably in
bed or maybe in the bath then to close
our eyes and direct our attention
towards one of many Tangled or murky
topics that we know deserve reflection a
partner a work challenge an invitation
an upcoming trip a relationship with a
child or a parent
we might need a moment to locate our
actual concern then disengage from the
ordinary static we should Circle the
matter and ask ourselves with unusual
guilelessness what's coming up for me
here
holding the partner work challenge
invitation or disagreement patiently in
mind we should whisper to ourselves
what do we really think what's the real
issue what is truly going on what is
actually at stake we should to sound a
little bit soft-headed ask ourselves
what our heart is Whispering to us or
what our gut is trying to articulate we
are striving to access a sincere part of
the mind too often crushed by The
Barking harried commands of the
conformist executive day-to-day self
what we will almost certainly find is
that in a quasi-mystical way the answers
are already there waiting for us like
the stars that were present all along
and only require the sun to fade in
order to come to light in the
circumference of the sky
we already know much more accurately
than we ever assume who we should be
friends with what is good and bad for us
and what our purpose on this Earth is we
just need to take the time to check in
on our true selves